it's great to connect with you uh how
are you how are you doing right now it's
uh
it's been crazy for a lot of people sure
yeah it's been an odd
odd few weeks but uh but yeah it's been
fun to put music out and
uh seems like the response for our song
has been really great so far and and so
that has been really
uh just an exciting thing that we've
gotten to be a part of
lately yeah chasing after you is it's a
beautiful song congratulations what
ultimately made you say this is the song
that you wanted to do duet with marion i
mean
you could have done it with other songs
but this must have been extra special
for you
we've recorded this song two or three
times and it's had a lot of versions and
the timing
just was was perfect and and it's a song
that a lot of people
in in nashville have known for a long
time and uh
i don't know i think it's a lot of
people's favorite song in nashville so
the fact that we had the opportunity to
record it and then the timing worked out
for us both
to be on a project like this was really
yeah i don't know it couldn't have
worked out any better
that's perfect and it begs the question
chasing after you
so you guys have been writing together
for a long time so who chase who who d
is slid into their dm did you make the
move did she make the move how did it
all happen
i think it was pretty mutual uh but i
mean that time in our life it's kind of
hard to
it's kind of hard to remember now just
because we have a baby now and
yeah it was you it was you who made the
first move i have a feeling
yeah i i probably was i like to say it
was her but that's just
uh i don't know it's f it's it's fun to
think back on that time and
um yeah obviously i think like just i
know
our situation now is not quite the same
as the song is but
um i think it's really i don't know i
think the timing for just a song about
longing from two people that have kind
of come through that story and
made it out the other side is really
yeah uh it really hits
people where in their heart and um i'm
excited about you know
getting to play it someday and the video
i mean
how did that video even happen it is
absolutely gorgeous
well uh we have a really good director a
great director tk mckamey
he's done tons of videos and country
music and i
and uh yeah i i actually like injured my
back the night before i don't have
back problems but i had to get up and do
all those
like choreographed moves on the rotating
floor and
uh so it was an interesting day i've
never uh never had to like
go through something like that i felt
like kind of an athlete that day we had
like a physical therapist come out and
but the video was was all tk and marin
coming up with the idea and
i told her i kind of i kind of worked on
the music part of it the most with my
producers and she did all of the visual
stuff so
uh yeah it's kind of fun to work as a
team with her musically i mean
we're our lives are so connected in
every other way that to get an
opportunity to come
together physically is just it kind of
feels really full circle
yeah and ryan i think you're the first
person i've spoke to that had a baby in
isolation and is turning one
which is ins i don't like how has the
experience been for you i mean
the silver lining is that you're home a
little bit more but how's it
you got to explain this to me i have two
kids at home i can't even imagine being
home all the time with the little one
how has it been for you i think the
difference between us and other people
as we travel so much that it was sort of
welcomed to be home as much with our kid
um but it has been odd i mean we
we had him right when the world shut
down so every little milestone is just
another month
that we've been dealing with this stuff
uh so it's it's sort of it's
double-edged a little bit but
you know i wouldn't have seen half of
the things that i would have been gone
half the time
right because he's gonna he would live
with marin on her bus right instead of
mine
so i would be kind of coming in and out
of the pictures and now
i got to spend like the entire first
year this kid's life at home with them
which is really i didn't miss anything
it's been really
really special do you have plans for his
birthday
we're working on it that's for sure we
still have to be careful in nashville
um but we're working on something um
trying to figure out what we want to do
but i'm sure it'll be like our families
at
just doing a party or something but yeah
it'll be cool i'm
i'm excited about having a one-year-old
that's nuts
it's crazy time flies doesn't it it
really does
and and it changes you it changes your
perspective on life
and becoming a dad um what have you
learned about yourself through this
process
i don't know no one's ever asked me that
i think um
you know i'm always trying to keep my
hands busy right i won't always
want to like be cleaning something or
changing a diaper or
there's you can't really sit around when
you have a kid if you want to you know
actually be a part of an equal part of
his life so
i uh i don't know but i've really
enjoyed like
this time with with hayes and this time
with marin and
i don't know if we'll ever have it
hopefully we'll never have it like this
again
right until we're we're done doing this
job but um
i don't know i think it's it's been
really cool to like learn
how to how to keep a child alive for a
year i guess
that's it's just all it's all really
just special and fun and i don't think
you have a whole lot of time to reflect
on it
until moments like this and your music i
know you're working on new music right
now
has that kind of this chapter in your
life kind of changed the way you look at
music now
oh man i you know it hasn't been like a
massively inspirational thing
for me musically i'm not writing a whole
bunch of songs about being a dad but i
think that it makes you focused
and i think it you know i think
everybody when they have a kid sort of
like
they sort of like realize how much more
they're responsible for now
so they take i think everything they do
a little more seriously so
i've been really lucky to you know make
music in nashville and that'd be my job
for the last few years and
and also to have you know a partner that
is doing exactly what she wants to do
in music so you know i hope hopefully
when
hayes grows up and sees you know his
parents you know really following
what they've been passionate about and
and somehow carving out a living doing
it
i i hope that it inspires him to like
kind of do the same thing i hope that he
finds something that he's really
passionate about and is able to like
really
like have a fulfilling life whether
that's his job or not you know
and both of you you know when you write
music um
do you check in with maron and see what
her opinion is on on your song or the
work that you're doing or vice versa is
she the person you go to and say
what do you think we play each other
music all the time
uh that's just i mean we it's fun that's
the fun part right it's getting a demo
back that you're really excited about
and sharing it with somebody and
um you know we've been writing for her
next album and so we've been doing a lot
of stuff
together and and it's already really i
mean i'm really excited about
everything she's doing and uh but yeah i
mean we
we love to share what we've been doing
and i she shares more than i do i write
a lot more than her so
a lot of i i like a lot less of what i
what i do
if that makes sense like she kind of
hits the target a lot more than i do
um i think but that's just different
styles of going to work
right like i kind of have to be the
volume guy and she's a little more
uh like calculated with the way that she
creates music so
um it's just it's fun though to like be
a part of her process whenever and and
you know
at the end of the day we always are a
part of the end product just because
we're the first ones that get to hear it
and you you made sure the song was
released before valentine's day which is
so great for the fans to enjoy something
like this
at a time like that uh did you have a
chance to kind of chill
and do something romantic or have you
been able to do anything romantic
um well i think that
i mean that's hard to say i mean we've
been like very carefully traveling for
the last month it feels like
so it's it feels like a little bit of a
groundhog day situation for us but but i
mean just the song itself coming out was
sort of our
our valentine's day moment because that
yeah
you know it was like so tied up in that
week and
and um you know seeing the fan response
and and other people really loving it
has been really special and that i think
that is
this kind of the thing that we sort of
did to celebrate valentine's day i
i always write these little cards too
from aaron on on like special days and i
like gave it to hayes
and he like chewed it up and i was like
i'll just give that to her anyway
because she'll like that more than
anything i say on it so
she got a chewed up valentine's day card
from me and hayes
perfect it's perfect uh crs is
highlights emerging artists and uh you
know you've got you've had an incredible
career
is there anything you learned that you
would take forward to someone who wants
to be in your position
in your and be an artist
man there's a lot of stuff i would say i
don't know how appropriate a lot of it
is but
uh i love i just love getting to do
this work i think all the other stuff
that comes along with it
whether it's attention or anything else
i mean it's all secondary to the fact
that you get to wake up every day and
make music in nashville tennessee
and um you know i always tell people
that it's a lot better to be good than
it is to be somewhere
so if you focus on that it really does
make your job a little bit easier it
shortens makes it smaller if that makes
sense so
you know i think that anybody who's
pursuing music especially in nashville
knows how special it is
and um i think every single day that i
get to wake up and do this
i'm really really thankful for it that's
amazing thank you so much ryan
congratulations on everything and i hope
isolation ends and you can go out and
celebrate and
you know the family could get to see
your little one as well so
absolutely thank you so much so much for
having me